a surge of press interest for federica
mogherini
the italian face of the eu abroad as
agreed by member states a month ago
but presenting herself here for
ratification by mep's
many had issues with her previous ties
to russia
and only brief time in office as italian
foreign minister
there was no mistaking the scale of her
workload we need to think
big and to do it together taking care of
our part of the world not only the
neighborhood
but also the neighbors of our neighbors
starting with ukraine and working
outwards eastwards and southwards to the
world's trouble spots
think of terrorism think of security and
defense we
need to develop more and more a common
framework
for common action to stop isil
which is not a state not
islam but a major global threat
in the middle east in particular the eu
has been an effective player needs to
become an effective player
meps wanted more details on specific
approaches
particularly with russia wildlife
experts say that if you're confronted by
a bear you can choose between standing
close to others in your group
or alternatively speaking softly and
reassuringly
gently retreating backwards if you
confront a russian bear miss mogherini
which tactic would you use
i would say that we need a mix of
assertiveness and diplomacy
the balance would also depend on the
reaction of the bear
diplomacy does not work we don't want
the military confrontation
ceasefire is not existing aggression
continues
so how do you intend to prepare us for
the worst case scenario i think that we
have to
work day by day by day
with president poroshenko to try and
make his
own efforts of dialogue and diplomacy
work
estonia knows plenty about threats from
neighbors
it was the victim in 2007 of a concerted
cyber attack blamed on moscow
that widely affected government and
commerce for andrus ansip
former prime minister now designate for
digital single market
building cyber defenses is a key task
globally
cyber attacks have jumped this year by
an estimated
48 percent compared with
2013. he went on to outline an
ambitious program stretching through
commerce and government
to bring europe fully into the digital
age with
digitalizing the wide area of public
services
we are only limited by our imagination
what national measures do you think
do you consider successful and how could
you foresee bringing them to the eu
level
for example invoice
it was it is not just it was
the real sex historian we have to
support sharing of those best practices
but let's put some breaks on the process
argued one mep
from the left shape
regulatory
as a liberal of course i believe in
markets but
i don't think market is able to solve
all the problems we have to do this
so from both commission hopefuls a plea
for more unity from member states to
give europe a bigger
more fitting place in the world